[Music]
this osha violation of an elevator that
starts moving before the doors close
also discount daniel day-lewis
if they can teleport why did we take the
work here steve same as you look
sometimes the characters in rick and
morty practically write these videos for
me which actually makes my job harder
because i have to get extra nitpicky to
justify my existence like pointing out
that this mail slot was not in the
establishing shot of the house that we
saw just a few seconds ago and nobody
likes it when i have to do that rick do
you need to drink in here yes not to
disregard the obvious alcoholism on
display here but the martini glass is
the most spillable adult beverage
container ever conceived there's been no
attempt at displaying any sort of
technology that would allow rick to fall
vertically through a portal without
spilling his drink some kind of alien
guga has infested the kennedy sex
tunnels the president concludes that it
must be alien guga without testing for
chlamydia first yeah that sounds fun
let's set some boundaries with a spoiled
control freak that thinks he runs the
world and orders drone strikes to cope
with his insecurity or some people call
it being a parent okay you're not gonna
have fun if you analyze everything morty
underestimates how much i enjoy my job
as far as he knows we're still in the
tunnels when should we reveal we can see
them show expects me to believe that
rick wouldn't immediately know that
there was a satellite spying on them or
that he wouldn't have some sort of
countermeasure in place that would blow
it up turn it into pudding or evolve it
into an ai capable of explaining that
building a spy satellite and getting it
into orbit is a huge waste of money when
everyone has a cell phone in their
pocket i mean what doesn't look bad
through an illegal spy satellite it's an
ice cream and yes yes yes yes you save
the world now and then and america
returns that favor by not holding the
two of you accountable to its laws any
of them any of the laws okay i can see
why turning a blind eye to some laws
would be necessary when dealing with
giant heads that kidnap the planet and
other assorted nuisances but all laws
you're telling me they could go to
arizona purchase a donkey and let it
sleep in a bathtub with no consequences
the production team makes a banger of a
song for a five second joke but has the
audacity to not make the banger of an
album we all paused the episode to
search for just promise if the results
are too strong you'll use protection by
results you mean summer's choice right
right how do you like that morty the
absence of torches here makes me
question why this scene does not contain
a rick and morty getting blown up by a
[ __ ] creeper that apparated out of
nowhere causing them to lose over one
thousand levels of xp farming and that
damn nephrite sword that they were
saving for just the right occasion
followed of course by having to work
their way back from who knows where to
assess the damage and pray to the ender
dragon that their carefully plotted cave
system has not been flooded or filled
with lava or you know something less
specific south park did it four years
ago morty you're fast or we're slow me
every time i carefully craft my own
version of the meme that i saw while
eating breakfast only to discover it has
somehow become a thing enjoyed being a
thing and is now no longer a thing
before my coffee is hit room temperature
also south park did that episode about
the simpsons already doing all the
things and how it doesn't matter so i
don't really have an excuse for not
making the meme and the writers don't
have an excuse for not giving us a
minecraft episode the only way using
this portal makes sense is if it's a
quicker option than the president just
flying there this means the portal would
have to already be there or at least be
closer than the president is but why why
would it be stationed in brazil do they
have one of these things in every
country aren't they super expensive and
why am i surprised that the government
has the ability to waste my money i made
sanchezium up dumbasses don't believe
everything you read on wikipedia well sh
excuse me while i go and review several
hundred of our videos for
reasons
i don't doubt a bar like this exists
somewhere in the multiverse but wouldn't
it make more sense for the footwear on
the torkasaurus sex to go all the way up
to the
heel inverted secondary knee whatever it
is this current setup does not look
twerkable what does this what what what
what does this mean this means nothing
just pull forward and park
uh even with all the sci-fi hijinks in
this episode somehow the show finds a
way to make one of the funniest moments
out of a simple frustration caused by
miscommunication thank you to everyone
involved and especially keith david for
bringing this hilarious character to
life israel and palestine have announced
a permanent ceasefire what they signed
something called the pretty obvious if
you think about it accord rick proving
he could do more to help mankind in an
afternoon than anyone else could do in
10 lifetimes but he'd rather dick around
in his garage cliche an anonymous
american diplomat took them to a star
wars cantina where they smoked
perspective-enhancing alien pheromones
through a laser hookah i see no laser i
demand a laser hookah oh and peace in
the middle east that too your approval
rating just hit 100 it is literally not
figuratively literally impossible for a
president to get a 100 approval rating
everyone could be rich healthy and never
exposed to war and some [ __ ] would
still say they have the right to be
homeless unhealthy and at risk of
high-velocity lead poisoning i was
knocking out a deterrent everyone wants
to be knocked out nobody wants to be
dead zack snyder explaining why his
version of batman kills bad guys instead
of subduing them somehow makes its way
into the episode doctor who and his
mother proclamations of being the doctor
do not make you the doctor and among
other things rick is approaching this
situation much more like a dalek i'd
love to understand how i can help you i
can't be in charge of that jerry my mind
my ideas are all part of the variable
the only constant is you this plan only
works if beth is correct in thinking
that there's some ineffable quality
inside all of us that no clone no matter
how perfect could ever fully replicate
and while you all sit there insisting
you would definitely know the difference
if your loved ones were replaced with
clones i'll be chatting to the ai that
built the simulation we live in senior
year i took you on a date skip and i
just thought lips don't sweat lips may
not sweat but the face around those lips
does sweat a fact that turned out to be
a deal breaker for
my freshman year episode makes a weird
metaphor about destroying conspiracy
surrounding the apollo moon landing the
kennedy assassination in 9 11. at least
i hope that's what they were going for
and we're hiding from you so you don't
kill her if she's a clone in a place i
pick that you will never find i think
morty is fastly underestimating rick's
ability to track i'm sure he has ways of
scanning for morty's dna or an army of
drones that scout the entire planet in
minutes or maybe he could just track the
[ __ ] cell phone that morty's decided
to keep you're a terrorist you're an
enemy of the state and you kicked me in
the balls ten minutes ago oh and all
those secret service people he killed
earlier but no need to bring that up i
suppose invisit troopers stand down why
are invisi troopers with knives
preferable to invisi troopers with
lasers i hope i could be of service if
uh you ever find the planet to be in
danger friends
sounds good to me the president thinks
he's making a deal with a rick from
another universe but what makes him
think that fly fishing rick would be any
better than regular rick he could be
just as murdery and insubordinate but
with the added annoyance of being one of
those people with a passion for
something hopefully you didn't just [ __ ]
around and waste your life
making us think mr poopy butthole is
going to be a fun call back then
tricking us into reflecting on all our
poor life decisions
tell him rick and morty just blew off
america hey phrasing yes yes yes yes you
save the world now and then america
returns that favor by not holding the
two of you accountable to its laws
diplomatic
community wouldn't go well
can you elaborate because of the
implication
what a rush
do you even know how to take out this
kind of threat you don't like my plan
that's good give me another plan but
don't tell me we're backing out doctor
who and this [ __ ] i have the
power of a thousand cowboys running
through my veins right now